bu
[Alkış]
konuşma hazırlığında önce kendi sar
tatlılık girişimin program nasıl
ulaştığını anlatmak istemiştim sonra
düşündüm ki
zaten birçok kişi kendi markası
yolculuğunu
eğitim hayatını uzun uzun anlatıyor
burada bir hikayeyi örneklendirmek
isteyenler zaten birçok e dinleyebiliyor
esas
takıldığım nokta veya Bizim dogal de
fark ettiğim şey dünya yok oluyor Daha
doğrusu küresel ısınma bizim farkında
olmadığımız kadar sert
ve önümüze gelmeye başladı Ben önce
girme Ziraat fakültesini bitirdim sonra
yüksek lisansını makine mühendisi de
tarımda uydu teknoloji üzerine yaptım
uydu Şu anda biz Elmas küllerinden
popüleri popüler diyorum atarım da
otonom çağı yakaladık dünyada ve tarım
teknolojisi üzerine dünyada peki ve
akademik alanda tek bir çalışma yoktu
Sonra işe yazmaya başladığımda bir
Türkiye'nin konvensiyonel bir tarım
televizyonun programcısı içerik
üreticisi sonra ticari anda yöneticisi
olduktan sonra hayalim bir televizyon
sahibi olmak
sonra 2019 yılında İş hayatına beş
yılında bir fırsat oldu ve Global de al
bu TV dünyanın 15 ülkesinde Türkiye'deki
operasyonlu
kurucu ortaklığında sonrasında
Türkiye'nin güçlü bir yatırımıyla
Türkiye'de dinamik Çevik yedirip yayın
anlayışı ortaya koydu tarımla ilgili
bu Yayıncılık anlayışını sürdüren kendi
artık
kurduğunuz Hayal sadece bir araç bir şey
edinmek ise bir süre sonra ne yapmak
istediğinin farkında olmuyorsunuz son
bir yıldır Belki bir buçuk yıldır bir
her ayın belki yarısını yurtdışında
oluyorum dünyadaki tarım ülkelerini
Tarım televiz ne olduğu yere yatırım
renginden olduğu yerlerde çeşitli
işbirlikleri ortaya koymaya çalışıyoruz
biz ne yapıyoruz önce gaz Çiftçi toplumu
anlatacaktın anlatmak istiyorum Biz
Türkiye'de Azerbaycan'da tarım eğlenceli
yapıyoruz ulusal uydu üzerinden yenilik
yapıyoruz dünyada Brezilya Nepal Romanya
Bulgaristan gibi ülkelerde yayınlar
sürüyor ama Çiftçi toplumu Türkiye'deki
toplumun yapısı Brezilya'daki veya
Hindistan'da ki de pek de farklı değil
dünyada 500 milyon Çiftçi var ve
Türkiye'de bu sayıyı 2.1 milyon kişi
Türkiye'deki Çiftçi yaş ortalaması 55
üzerinde dünyadaki toplam yaş ortalaması
Ayşe göre 58 60 civarında ve dünyadaki
500 milyon Çiftçi dünya toplamda 7
milyar insanı doyurmaya çalışıyorum
fakat
2019'da başlayan pandemi krizinde
gıdanın bir bağımsızlık meselesi
olduğunu tedarik zincirleri bu yönde
birlikte anladık pandemi de 6 milyon ve
pandilli Sınıfta kaldık ve tüm dünya
ülkelerini baz aldığımızda pandemi de 6
milyon kişi
hayatını kaybetti tüm dünyada ve gıda
tedarik zincirinde de çok ciddi akşamlar
yaşadık ve şu anda dünyada bir milyon
kişi obezite ile mücadele ederken
dünyada aynı zamanda yine 1 milyon kişi
açlıkla mücadele ediyor Yani dünya
insanları doyurmak için çok fazla
çeşitliliğe sahip iken
aynı insanları açlığa mahkum edebilir
onda veya
2900 yılında Birleşmiş Milletler Dünya
ülkeleriyle birlikte Afrika 100 milyar
dolarlık bir yatırım yapmayın gördüğünde
bugünkü rakamda aradan onbir oniki yıl
geçmesine rağmen toplamda 1 milyar
dolara ulaşmış değiliz dünya
zenginliklerini hammadde olarak tedarik
bırak kullanırken aynı zenginliği
biyoçeşitlilikte yönetemiyorum ve
şekillendiriyoruz 11 araba Ali önemli
arıyor Türkiye'deki sosyal sorumluluk
vakıflarında sürekli çıkardı bu konuda
gerekli anladığı bunu sık sık
kullanıldığını görüyorsunuz dünyadaki
biyoçeşitliliğin yakında üretimde
devamlılığı için ağrının yaşamanı polen
salgısını çekti ve geometrik bizi
gerekiyor Biz araları mızda yok oluyor
İyi okuyor Çünkü dünya bitki koruma yani
tarım ilacı zehirini
sürekli kullanarak kimyasal gübreyi
sürekli kullanarak sentetik bir gıda
üretiminde ortaya koymak için
biyoçeşitliliği yok ederek bir görüntü
elde etmeye çalışıyoruz Bu ürünlerde
böyle bir vahşileşti ki öyle bir noktaya
geldi ki dünyanın küreselci
büyük teknoloji şirketleri daha iyi
tırnak içinde vicdana gelmiş olsalar ki
ki öyle bir şey yok dünyanın
sürdürebildiği viskinin herkesi çok net
görüyor bir gece iklim krizi de mücadele
isminde bir kitap çıkar Evet Ee bu
kitapta da
küresel iklim değişikliğinin dünyadaki
dünyaya verdiği zararı ve önlenebilecek
önlenmesi noktasında neler
yapılabileceğini anlatmaya çalıştım ve
Vakıf kurdu kendisi Buna göre yaşama
dönmeye çalıştığı Hatta 2016 yılında
Paris iklim Anlaşması da 197 ülkenin
buluşması noktasında bir milyar doların
üzerinde de Kendi şirketi üzerinden Son
aktardaki Buluşma sağlanabildiği orada
küresel iklim değişikliğini önlemek
amacıyla tarife değil özel uçağıyla
fosil yakıt tüketerek
197 ülkenin katıldığı Paris iklim
Anlaşması 2016'nın da 191 ülke iklim
değişikliğinin farkını harekete geçmek
istiyorum dedim alt ülke buna hayır dedi
bir Türkiye idi ta ki geçen yıla kadar
barkı küresel iklim değişikliğinin biz
geçen yıla kadar kabul etmedik kabul
etmek ne anlama geliyor üretimde
otomasyonlu insanda doğada herşey ve
yaşamın canın olduğu her yerde iklim
değişikliğini uyma zorunluluğu kabul
etmiş anlamına geliyorsunuz Biz tabi
ihracat odaklı bir büyümeyle
kendi ekonomi sürdüğümüz ortaya
koyduğumuz ifade ettiğimiz için şu anda
dizisinin Filiz iklim değişikliğinin
önüne koyması uygun zaman değil denilmiş
ki eski bu şimdi bir noktaya değişmiş
oldu Neden küresel iklim değişikliği
konusunda atıyorum Bizim Türkiye'de
ulusal bilinci olmanın farklı ülkelerde
ilik yapmanın onlarca kişiyle
bu dünyada
Yayıncılık konforla erişmenin insan
olarak keyfi ama toplumu hiçbir Eğer
farkındadır yoksa katkısı yok
bulursanız medya kuruluşları siyasi
Tekelde genelde politik araçlarla
yönetildiği ve
kurumsallaştırılması için Türkiye için
bahsetmem tüm dünya için geçerli Bu 11
bu konusunda doğal konusunda eğitim
konusunda maalesef orta bitti rica yok
Biz kendi adımıza şunu ifade etmeye
çalışıyoruz Sürdürülebilir üretim yoksa
gıda yok gıda yoksa açtık var var açtık
varsa huzursuzluk var tam tersi bu işin
fayda tarafı biyoçeşitlilik yoksa iklim
yoksa biyolojik yok iklim yoksa gelecek
yok Gelecek nesil denizin yaşam alanı
yok bunu düzgün bir zemin değer ortaya
kullanıyorsanız
bizim bugünkü yaşamış olduğumuz her şeyi
ulaşan her şeyi bolluk içinde
tükettiğimiz toplumdaki varlığımız 50
yıl sonra kötü bir miras olarak bizden
sonraki nesillere acı bir faturaya
kalacak Biz bu faturanın bedelini ödemek
istemiyoruz dünyada enerji ile birlikte
bir savaş maalesef krizler dönüyor
başladı bunu şuraya bağlıyorum ifade
etmek istedim Rusya Ukrayna krizi
o
etmedi alttan tipi avrasya'nın enerjide
gıdada da coğrafya
ortak kaderimizi paylaşımı coğrafyadaki
paylaşım Aslında krizi bu krize
bizi önce marketleri ya almaya koşarak
gittik bu krizde tahıl haberleri Sükan
hakkında görüyoruz Biz bir buçuk yıl
öncesine kadar Türkiye'nin sildik bir
yayıncılığın ortaya kurarken bugün bütün
akıllı televizyonları Bizim yaptığımız
haberleri yapıyor tahıllı gemisi yolda
mı ya fiyatı ne olacak Çiftçi üretimi
yapabiliyor mu süt fiyatları nereye
gidiyor gibi konuları tartışıyoruz bu
niye tercih Çünkü acı faturayı böyle
tüketicimiz market raflarına gittiği
zaman beni görmeye başlıyor Peki Rusya
Ukrayna krizi örneğini tanıma ve gıdaya
nasıl bakmalıyız
Rusya sadece dünyadaki takalım yüzü
80'ini karşılıyor
bu köy la sadece Türkiye'nin yağ
ihtiyacını 155 İnik bu
Türkiye 9 milyon hektar alanda buğday
üretiyor toplamda 19000000 tam buğday
rekoltesinin yani hasat verildiğine
sahibiydi aynı buğdayı Almanya 5 milyon
hektar alanda yarı Toprak alanıyla 30
milyon ton elde ediyor Biz dışa bağımlı
bir ülkeyiz buğdayda yağda Gıda ürünleri
na na Tüm Elif maddeleri dışa bağımlı
bir ülkeyiz dışa bağımlılık ne Biz bugün
vergilerle kasayı
doldurduğumuz bu ekonomideki varlığımızı
üretim siz limmy's verimsizliği biz ve
yanlış politikalarımız nedeniyle de
dönüyoruz yurtdışındaki çiftçiye daha
fazla para geri veriyoruz Bunu
klasiki yansıması da bu konuyla alakası
var diye bakımdan şöyle Bizler gibi
coğrafyası mezopotamya'dan gelmiş 16 bin
yıllık tarihi köklere sahiptir
coğrafyada üretim çeşit bu dünyadaki
Toplam 11 video kime özelliğinin sekizin
karşılandığı bir coğrafyada üretimi çok
iyi bilen videoda feda Ata tohumlarla
olarak bahsettiğimiz devletimizin 800
bin yıllık ağaçlarıyla bağlılığını hala
sürdüğü coğrafyada
üretim yetersizliği mi üretim
bilinçsizliği mizi dışa bağımlı rakı ne
diyoruz Peki bu genç nesille biz ne
yapacağız çiftçimiz Hayır biz gıdada
sürdürülebilirlik için İmam Hatip
yaklaşımları dünya ülkeleriyle eşgüdümlü
bir şekilde bunun adı start-up olur
bunun adı yükseklikleri fark etmeksizin
bu hukukta irade göstermeniz hangi iş
yapıyorsak Yapalım işimiz sonu gıda
üretimine ve buradaki büyümeler e
geliyor sabahki konuşmalarımıza
beyefendi değişti Bir bir zincirin
evleri sipariş veren bir zincirin
örneğini paylaştı O da sonunda
motosikletin
bu şekilde ne bir daha taşıyor bu daha
Farkında da biz dünya ülkelerine
yapıyorlar bakmalıyız önce Fransız
anlatayım hazır uygun yer Fransa Türkiye
dünyanın
tarım Omuzdaki en örgüt ülkesinin Fransa
Tarım Bakanlığı tüm sivil toplum
örgütlerini kamu yararına çalışıp bir
şekilde Çiftçi örgütleri süt ibretler
örgütleri üzüm üreticileri örgütleri
gibi üreticileri Bakanlığı çatısı
altında toplamış üretim deseni elde 55
yıldır planı yapan bu planladi şansı
bazı şekeri kullanmayan Yani bu duyguyu
gideceğiz şurubunu kullanmayan
çiftçisinin dünya ortalamasında yük
refah sahip ülke fransa'dır artık
ithalat noktasında eksi vermeye başladı
Peki nedeni de Çünkü dünyada Challenge
gibi Hindistan gibi Brezilya gibi
ülkelerde Muazzam agresif bir Savaş
başladı için 15 Bu gördüğünüz görselde
için 2025 vizyonun 11 maddelik bir
bir manifestosunu bunun bir kalemi Tarım
Gıda ve Çin 30 yıl önce
gereki hala ki bir ülke iken tarım
konusunda bugün ki
dünyanın en büyük ihracat ülkesi tarımda
dünyanın en büyük bir Talat Ülkesi
Hollanda gibi örnek fark belki gelirsem
Hollanda'nın
Hollanda Çin demokrasi edilebilir
Doktora bile değil Hollanda'da limon
larıyla Ticaret kabiliyetiyle ta
İspanyol keşiflerin tam Marco Polo kadar
serüvenin sonrası ticaretinden Ticaret
hacmiyle tarımda ihracat rakamı
güçlendirmiş bir ülkedir üreten güçlü
bir etki değildir Toprak alanda ve
bağlama uygun değilim için iki önceki
Trump için savaşında 300 milyar dolarlık
bir ambargoyu gıda var mı Az önce kadar
net bir duruş ortaya koyduğu bu örnekte
Hindistan nüfusuyla ve toplam 5 milyon
çift örneğini vermiştim 250000000 Çiftçi
Dünyada sadece Nisan'da yaşıyor
Hindistan toplam nüfusunun yüzde yirmi
dik belki toplamdaki tarım ekosistemi
ile dünyanın en büyük oyuncu olmaya
başladı için Hindistan Brezilya gibi
ülkeler çok net gıda milliyetçiliğin
ortaya koyduğu Milliyetçilik bir
tutuculuk değildir Bu bir bağımsızlık
tekelinde Savaşı'nda kendi insanlar
sürdürebilir ortaya koymayan çalışma ile
ilgili bir yaklaşımda bir tanımlama Daha
doğrusu şimdi Türkiye'de bu örnekte
baktığımız zaman
yeni bir tane mümkün mü ya yeni bir
kahramanlık ortaya koymak mümkün mü Evet
bir kere Türkiye'ye Cumhuriyet Devrimi
ve Köy Enstitüleri hamlesiyle dünyada
bu birinci Ufuk etmiş ve buna irade
göstermiş
çok
köklerinde güçlü deneye sahiptir ülke
aynı şekilde Biz kendi hikayemizde
örnekleme 2016 yılında bir televizyonun
çay çalışan iken Bursa'nın Karacabey
ilçesinde bir çiftçi fark etti bu Çiftçi
de bir Alman profil dergisi çiftçinin
Hikâyesi yazmış Ben de eğitim geliyorum
okurken İngilizcen okurken bir çiftçi
farkettim ki böyle bir çift devam edin
müthiş otomasyon kullanıyor teknoloji
kullanıyor Çiftlikte bir inekten 40
bileti süt alıyor traktörleri kendi
yürüyor enteresan bir çiftçi Çiftçi
Sencer Solakoğlu ve şu anda bu
Instagram'da bakın 100.000 takipçi Var
YouTube'da bilmem kaç bin abonesi var
tek kişi çiftçilik yapmak bu kişilik
Örneğin Dede Türkiye'deki ana akımı en
önemli görüş paylaştığı Biz ve bu Sencer
Solakoğlu örneği de Türkiye'de farklı
bir örnek yapılabilir ortaya koydu tarım
dün Ben de aynı toparlıyorum tarım
Dünyanın her yerinde aynı üretim her
yerinde aynı bir Sadece üç tane ülke
yönetiyoruz ama ya 15 ülkesinde
organizasyon sürüyor özet özellikle gıda
milliyetçiliği artık önümüzde çok sık
iğne başlayacak üretim bağımsız bölümde
çok sık iğne başlayacak 7 saat haplar
gıdanın daha Sürdürülebilir iklimde
barışçı bir şekilde varlığını sürdürmesi
ile ilgili girişimleri kabul edecek bu
girişimler Önümüzdeki dönemlerde büyük
kilolarla büyük satın almalar önlü
getirmeye başlayacak bunu sağlamak için
sadece
dünyadaki önceki iklim değişikliği
hassasiyetini farkındalığını ve buradaki
girişimler ortaya koymak gerekiyor iklim
değişikliği konusu Adrasan romantizm
değil de dünyada kullanılabilen
toplantısı vardı yüzde bir tatlı Suvarlı
yüzde biri yüzde bir yüzde yüzlük
birinde baz aldığımız zaman biz yüz
75'lik suyumuzu tarımda vahşi sulama ile
kullanıyoruz yani bize Ne mutlu biraz
kapattık duşu 13 dakikada aldık işte
gelip çatıları mıza yağmurlama sistemi
kurduk bunların hiçbirinin iklim
değişikliği önemi yeterli yok Önemli
yeterli yok o yüzden sürdürebildiği
ortaya koymak lazım mu ufukta dünyayı
takipçimiz gerekiyor çünkü dünyadaki
yeni ülkeler Güneşin doğduğu ülkeler Çin
gibi Sanki Brezilya gibi ülkeler çok
agresif bir şekilde Türkiye'de sıkıştı
ithalatçı bir ülke modunu moduna bizim
maalesef sokuyor O yüzden gelecek
hislerimizin bu farkındalıkla sadece
Gelecek kaygısı dediğin yaşam konforunu
değil dünyanın hassasiyetiyle tüm
iradesini ortaya konması gerekiyor
teşekkür ederim sağ ol